yeah I know and welcome to this video
playing I've never yeah after I DSP
tough to say how this should be
pronounced the Mora not played at all so
CD for the pre move is a bit bit strange
okay so be sure to be five in this
version of Bishop b5 doesn't feel all
that dangerous to me to be honest the
night committed to c3 the fields less
dangerous you see going for before yeah
it seems on and it's the only logical
explanation for the movie three till now
I now take the spawn
I don't believe in this movie should be
393 maybe maybe maybe yes maybe I should
just play d6 and decline everything thus
could indeed be somewhat tricky takes
takes Bishop t6 yeah yeah I should have
not played this so quickly so after the
capture 95 is this point it's definitely
true I cannot play a 5 this is something
that I should have thought about really
should've very tough position very tough
position
so we can just take on d4 at the end
20x9 is a double attack this is this a
simple chest but it's good
yeah the problem is he can also take on
before now in guindy 495 might still be
worth playing the other one was stronger
yeah I can fight with the exchange down
I've got a pawn maybe it just takes with
Twiggy porn actually group g8 is not
exactly a great move to play okay so
Knight f6 is 11 move 19 f form or this
one try and try it for the ending at
this time of major than and I have two
bishops there i mean the ending isn't
clear ok it doesn't play at the ending
which is probably right and add the real
opening disaster I should have thought
about this a little bit harder so I know
the whole opening looked looked weird
but I probably should have just not
taken the thing just play 86 or
something ok so am I somehow made it
there Queen hae door it's tough to move
really this happiness always under fire
something like b6 Bishop e7 would be
cool but getting this in it's not easy
at all
now there's so much pressure on the d7
pawn okay i'm not sure if he has like
full full on wind down he's an exchange
up I mean he might just play Queen a
jade and my queen age eighteen seventeen
have six or so but this won't be easy
and he's taking a long long long time
okay so yeah I don't have something good
he's six doesn't threaten anything maybe
a trans rupee eight threaten intending I
would be eight and then be five and get
stuff developed finally it's taking so
much time is he threatening g4 here in
this position that could be a key that
could be the case yeah wow what the
fricking frick ah now I understand he
wants to take the rook there ah ok but i
have to should i wait for one thing or
what is the point what is the point of
this Wow
really why does that work and sorry I
don't get that I'm just going to e7 here
right I feel like I'm overlooking
something I earned okay what is going on
here happy seven covered my king is
absolutely safe here the easiest is
probably up to aid now okay now check
check
back rank is extremely weak take care
Queen at 77 v7s China problematic only
not on ok just a tech the book doesn't
have good squares anyway and I just
ripped it one leg songs not bad like
four days old and I was a very lucky
wind I mean a very lucky wind I just
played the opening terribly really i
mean this is ok and now here i should
just probably not take or maybe take as
the engine suggests takes on before and
then not take on before I mean I was
kind of that was just yeah I was just
not thinking that this is any good
anyway and I was bad naughty I'm in
terrible shape I mean that is the
engines it suggestion until you stick it
is just bad cannot move at all but it's
probably better than what I did I mean
this now is just lost I'm just lost here
yeah and he played that right and now
instead of Queen takes which does win
hey yeah but still this was easier I
thought this is just a piece for for
absolutely nothing ok this is also wins
with eat eggs they either suggested yeah
that's probably pretty strong this
position is completely lost
how yeah it was it's really one of the
worst opening results i can remember to
have idea i was really happy i let the
game continued and it's it's completely
gone whoop t6 is a good move oh yeah
like this it's made that the engine find
a mate it came they took check lots of
weirdness to be good here in this
position she should be should be seven
let's just not spit in it explicable see
i just take everything and I'm fine okay
Jim that's a bit mysterious and very
lucky I was a really terrible opening
play ok guys thanks for watching